we've been hearing from a lot of
self-proclaimed cultural Christians this
year they're all over social media and
some of them are quite famous not long
ago we talked about cultural Christian
Richard
Dawkins we are culturally a Christian
country and I call myself a cultural
Christian I love hymns and Christmas
carols and I sort of feel at home in the
Christian ethos I feel that we are a
Christian country in that sense I would
not be happy if um for example we lost
all our Cathedrals and our beautiful
Parish churches more recently Elon Musk
said he considers himself a cultural
Christian I'm actually a big believer in
in in the principles of Christianity um
I think they're very good so in what
sense then are you not
religious well so Dawkins just came out
three weeks ago or thereabouts and
announced that he was a cultural
Christian right and so the question
right I I would say I'm I'm probably a
cultural Christian I was I was brought
up as a Anglican and I was baptized
these cultural Christians are convinced
that Christian principles help produce
good
societies when when Dawkins announced he
was a cultural Christian the question
that came to my mind right away was okay
there's a bunch of things going on there
the first is Dawkins Proclamation or
admission that if you compared different
societies and their axiomatic
suppositions he would prefer the ones
predicated on Christian axiomatic
assumptions I I do think those are good
ones if I had to choose between
Christianity and Islam I choose
Christianity every single time I mean it
seems to me to be a fundamentally decent
religion in so far as Christianity can
be seen as a bulock against Islam I
think it's it's a very good thing I mean
I find that I like to live in a
culturally Christian country in Africa
for example um where you have
missionaries of both faiths operating um
I'm I'm I'm on team Christian side as
far as that's concerned now if we Define
a cultural Christian as a person who
doesn't believe that Jesus is the Divine
Son of God who died on the cross for
sins and rose from the dead but who has
nevertheless been positively influenced
by the teachings of Christian
then there are three main kinds of
cultural Christians one there are
cultural Christians who don't know that
they've been influenced by Christianity
two there are cultural Christians who
know that they've been influenced by
Christianity but they're hostile towards
Christianity people like Richard Dawkins
and three there are cultural Christians
who know that they've been influenced by
Christianity and they're not hostile
towards Christianity people like Elon
Musk if you're watching this video and
you're not a believing Christian you're
probably a cultural Christian in some
sense because the teachings of Jesus
have worked their way to some extent
into just about everyone's thinking even
in places where there aren't many
Christians and I find that very
interesting because we were were told
this was going to happen long before
anyone could have thought about it
actually happening in Genesis 1818 God
declares Abraham will surely become a
great and powerful nation and All
Nations on Earth will be blessed through
him in Genesis 2217 to18 the angel of
the Lord who according to many Christian
theologians is the pre-incarnate Christ
the second person of the Trinity says I
will surely bless you and make your
descendants as numerous as the stars in
the sky and as the sand on the seashore
your descendants will take possession of
the cities of their enemies and through
your Offspring All Nations on Earth will
be blessed because you have obeyed me so
all nations on Earth would be blessed
through Abraham's
offspring the great irony here here is
that you've been so thoroughly blessed
by God fulfilling that promise that you
don't understand how absolutely insane
it would have sounded in the time of the
Patriarchs for multiple reasons
obviously it would have sounded insane
because Abraham was almost 100 years old
and Isaac hadn't even been born
yet almost as obviously it would have
sounded insane that some sheep herder
was hearing voices telling him that his
offspring would be a blessing to all s
we can understand those issues but the
really insane part the part that we
can't comprehend now because our
thinking is so radically different is
this in the time of the Patriarchs other
nations were very frequently your
enemies you didn't want to be a blessing
to your enemies the various Nations that
were going to conquer and oppress you
there was no concept of seeking the good
of all people and yet it was built into
the thinking of the children of Israel
that it was their job to be a blessing
to All
Nations you can see various fulfillments
of this promise for instance look up a
list of Nobel Prize winners and prepare
to be shocked by how disproportionately
Jewish they are spoiler alert over 20%
of Nobel Prize winners are Jews even
though Jews make up 2% of the world's
population quite a
blessing but from a Christian
perspective the main fulfillment of
God's promise that Abraham's offspring
would be a blessing to All Nations is a
descendant of Abraham named Jesus and
this is especially relevant in a
discussion about cultural Christians in
the book of Acts chapter 3 we read about
Peter and John two Disciples of Jesus
two more descendants of Abraham healing
a man in the name of Jesus and then
preaching to more descendants of Abraham
Watch What
Happens one day Peter and John were
going up to the temple at the time of
prayer at 3 in the afternoon now a man
who was lame from birth was being
carried to the Temple Gate called
Beautiful where he was put every day to
beg from those going into the temple
courts when he saw Peter and John about
to enter he asked them for money Peter
looked straight at him as did John then
Peter said look at us so the man gave
them his attention expecting to get
something from them then Peter said
silver or gold I do not have but what I
do have I give you in the name of Jesus
Christ of Nazareth walk taking him by
the right hand he helped him up and
instantly the man's feet and ankles
became strong he jumped to his feet and
began to walk then he went with them
into the temple courts walking and
jumping and praising God when all the
people saw him walking and praising God
they recognized him as the same man who
used to sit begging at the Temple Gate
called beautiful and they were filled
with wonder and amazement at what had
happened to him while the man held on to
Peter and John all the people were
astonished and came running to them in
the place called Solomon's colonade when
Peter saw this he said to them fellow
Israelites why does this surprise you
why do you stare at us as if by our own
power or godliness we had made this man
walk the god of Abraham Isaac and Jacob
the god of our fathers has glorified his
servant Jesus you handed him over to be
killed and you disowned him before
Pilate though he had decided to let him
go you disowned the holy and righteous
one and asked that a murderer be
released to you you killed the author of
life but God raised him from the dead we
Are Witnesses of this by faith in the
name of Jesus this man whom you see and
know was made strong it is jesus' name
and the faith that comes through him
that is completely healed him as you can
all see now fellow Israelites I know
that you acted in ignorance as did your
leaders but this is how God fulfilled
what he had foretold through all the
prophets saying that his Messiah would
suffer repent then and turn to God so
that your sins may be wiped out that
times of refreshing may come from the
Lord and that he may send the Messiah
who has been appointed for you even
Jesus Heaven Must receive him until the
time comes for God to restore everything
as he promised long ago through his holy
prophets for Moses said the Lord your
God will raise up for you a prophet like
me from among your own own people you
must listen to everything he tells you
anyone who does not listen to him will
be completely cut off from their people
indeed beginning with Samuel all the
prophets who have spoken have foretold
these days and you are hires of the
prophets and of the Covenant God made
with your fathers he said to Abraham
through your Offspring All Peoples on
Earth will be blessed when God raised up
servant he sent him first to you to
bless you by turning each of you from
your wicked
ways so according to the Apostle Peter
and generations of Christians after him
The Offspring of Abraham through whom
all nations would be blessed was Jesus
God took one man Abraham out of the
entire world and then made a nation out
of that man then God took one man Jesus
from that nation and made him a blessing
to the entire world when the book of
Acts was written Christianity was a tiny
persecuted sect of Judaism here again
because we're familiar with the impact
of Jesus we can't even comprehend how
completely utterly totally insane
Peter's little sermon would have
sounded hey everyone you know that guy
who was just crucified by the Romans
like so many other guys were crucified
by the Romans yeah he's The Offspring of
Abraham who's going to be a blessing to
All
Nations Peter would have sounded
positively
deranged but hindsight is 2020 as the
saying goes here we are nearly 2,000
years after Peter said that all nations
would be blessed through the guy who got
nailed to AC Cross by the Romans and
we've got Oxford atheists and Tech
Geniuses telling the world how they've
all been blessed by Jesus of Nazareth
The Offspring of
Abraham coincidence
[Music]